thank you Father's Day weekend should be
spent with laughs love and barbecues of
course la Bonita supermarket has plenty
of specials to get your grill Doan JC is
at their new Green Valley location let's
check back in with him hey JC hey
Lindsey Rocky I'm gonna take this off
because we're here at la Bonita the
brand new store sunset and Green Valley
Parkway I'm here with Celeste and we're
gonna do some eatin we got some food
Celeste
this is one of the father's day combos
that you guys have what do we have in
front of us I am super excited for this
combo this year we did not have it last
year so I'm super super excited for
59.99 you get this whole feast right
over here $59 you get everything that's
on the table here we are trying to make
it good for everyone to just come to one
place and get everything you need and go
home so you get everything that's on
this table
what JC's eating enjoying right now
those are famous chicken wings and then
he also has to be chair right on his
plate which is amazing you get the two
different sauces you get the two type of
different tortillas and they're our
famous amazing fresh carnitas I have
tables what is it where do we have the
pork so that is pork carnitas all right
what you're eating makes what the
ceviche looks like you had a whole thing
in your in your yes your meat it is so
juicy I'm not about it but I have a
father and he would love this I know
he's watching he would love it so let's
talk about this to meet you because I
know there's different flavors that you
guys offer there are different kinds of
ceviche Lana I'm having right now this
is a shrimp ceviche again made at the
store every day with all the safety
precautions that we are taking we are
still making this with fresh ingredients
fresh out of there so this you can come
and get it and go so now the chicken the
seasoning on the chicken so now am I'm
getting this and just eating it up
what am I getting isn't preparing
everything at home no it's ready for you
to take it you don't have to cook
anything everything is ready for you you
just make it take it
and put it on the table Celeste this is
absolutely amazing cheers Aussie a beer
as well right Cheers like I wrap it up
coming back to the studio
here's the celebrating that mr. Wow my
my first meal was so on besides my wife
this is an amazing experience thank you
guys so much happy Father's Day
we send it back to you guys this to do
rocky and Lindsey for you thank you
bring all that back here it looks good
there are now 7-eleven e two
supermarkets in Las Vegas so click on
bonito markets.com to find location
nearest you